behold the Dreadful yet beautiful coral
snake
bright Reds act as a signal warning
predators of the deadly potent
neurotoxins of its venom glands just one
single bite is enough to
wait a minute here there is a poem that
I learned as a Cub Scout to help us tell
the difference between a deadly coral
snake and a harmless milk snake red on
yellow kills a fellow red on black venom
black
supposing that the poem I learned in Cub
Scouts is legitimate and no guarantees
there this is not a deadly coral snake
it's a completely harmless milk snake
sometimes called a king snake today
we're going to look at how warning
colors evolved and we're going to
examine the evolution of the milk snakes
lie
evolutionary question number 31
how does mimicry evolve
most animals are brown or green they
have evolved to match their environment
which helps them hide hiding is usually
important for both predators and prey
animals so it's obvious how this evolves
but people have long noted that toxic
and venomous animals are often brightly
colored it's like they're trying to
stand out what's the deal here how does
this evolve
to explore how this could have happened
we can use a thought experiment imagine
the ancient ancestors of the coral snake
imagine them before their bright colors
evolved now we don't actually know what
color they were before evolving bright
Reds but let's assume they looked
something like this garter snake with a
slight red tint and that red tint had
nothing to do with how venomous they
were it's just the color that they had
bears and many other animals like to eat
snakes but of course Bears don't like to
be bitten by venomous snakes and it
turns out that in the wild bears don't
mess with venomous snakes they can tell
the difference how does that happen just
like humans individual Bears seem to
have innate differences in how
frightened they are of specific things
they can learn to be more or less
frightened as well just using their
brain because they're smart but mammals
all seem to start with default instincts
as children so these are heritable or
genetically influenced phobias if a bear
is born in a region filled with deadly
slightly red colored coral snakes and
delicious harmless brown snakes sorry
for the laptop in this stock footage
here I'm doing what I can with what I
have if a bear is born in a region with
both reddish coral snakes and harmless
brown snakes any bear that happens to be
weirded out by red spots happens to have
an innate phobia well it's going to be
less likely to try to eat a red tinted
snake it's not going to mess with them
therefore it will survive and reproduce
better than those who don't have this
strange new phobia getting bitten and
end up being sick for weeks some of them
even dying possibly I mean the the
snakes could hypothetically kill a bear
their neurotoxins can definitely ruin a
bear's week a precious week of food
Gathering which puts that bear at a huge
survival disadvantage the phobia of red
tinted snakes if that's a heritable
phobia it will be passed on to The
Offspring at least some of the offspring
of that bear it's going to spread in the
population over evolutionary time from
generation to generation as this happens
any coral snake born with a mutation
that just so happens to make its bright
pigments more intense those snakes are
less likely to be confused by bears for
brown snakes they're less likely to be
accidentally attacked by bears who are
trying to stay away from red snakes here
we see that a feedback loop is generated
the Bears are evolving to be better
recognizers of red coral snakes and
coral snakes are evolving to be more red
the red tint which started out as a cue
that the bear was picking up on is now
magnified by the snake over evolutionary
time the snake went from passively or
you could say accidentally transmitting
a cue a cue that bears picked up on to
actively transmitting a signal the
bright red is a signal saying stay away
I am venomous
this is how signals are thought to
evolve from cues this is an honest
signal it's a win-win the bear avoids
getting bit the snake avoids being eaten
honest signaling can be found everywhere
in nature bacteria signal to each other
potential mates signal to each other
predators and potential prey signal to
each other and they often do this
honestly along with honest signaling
however dishonest signaling can emerge
remember that delicious harmless brown
snake with the laptop if a random
mutation happens to give one of them red
spots as well they might be confused for
a venomous snake if so they will also
survive and reproduce better than their
non-red-spotted kin this mimicking trait
can spread through the population as
Generations pass that mimic can be
augmented until it looks almost
identical to the real thing that's the
general theory of how warning signals
evolve and how mimics evolve this seems
to make sense but is it true it turns
out that nobody has actually witnessed
the evolution of a signal from a queue
from start to finish because it's so
hard to capture the very beginnings of
these systems in recent years some
really good work has been done out of
Oxford what they do is they use bacteria
which evolve quickly so you can actually
just watch them evolve in the lab and
they were able to disrupt bacterial
signaling systems and then measure
responses they would disrupt them in
different ways and they would predict
ahead of time using signaling Theory how
the bacteria would respond to these
various degrees of disruption this was a
way to test whether or not signaling
theory is actually legitimate does
signaling Theory produce real accurate
predictions what they found is that yes
it does it really is an accurate Theory
bacteria are great because they evolve
rapidly but it's also really hard to
watch what they're doing in order for us
to trace the signals they're sending to
each other those signals have to be
strong the this means that it's nearly
impossible to capture the actual origin
of a signal because by default these
signals they start out weak right well
recently a group of scientists found a
way to sort of cheat this system instead
of trying to watch the evolution of
signals and animals which takes forever
because animals have long generation
times or instead of trying to watch it
happen in bacteria which is really hard
because it's difficult to detect weak
signals they set up Evolution
experiments inside of a computer now
obviously this isn't as cool as
capturing evolution in the wild or in a
laboratory experiment there's always the
danger that your simulation is missing
something really important some variable
that has a huge effect on what actually
happens in real life but simulations are
a great start and in this case maybe you
could argue that this is the best option
we currently have so what they did is
they set up populations of toxic and
non-toxic individuals and allowed
predators to evolve from among them the
program they used is Avita which allows
you to set up populations of digital
organisms little individual programs
represented in this presentation as
colored pixels each program starts with
specific parameters they're capable of
reproduction and when they reproduce
random heritable changes in their
program are also generated this
simulates mutation the experiment did
not test these signal magnification
aspect that we talked about earlier the
red tint to the bright red coloration
instead they started with toxic prey
that quote look obviously different from
non-toxic prey and by look I mean they
have a tag in their program a tag that
other programs may or may not be able to
recognize and if the Predator programs
can recognize the tag they may or may
not treat those tagged prey items
differently from other prey items the
way that tagged prey items are treated
as one of the variables that's evolving
in this simulation what they found is
that Predators quickly over evolutionary
time over multiple Generations evolved
to recognize and avoid toxic prey items
this was just descent with modification
acted upon by selection this is similar
to how in our thought experiment the
Bears evolved to recognize and fear the
red snakes
as predators in the system evolved to
avoid the toxic prey items the tags on
non-toxic prey items began evolving to
look more and more like the tags on
toxic prey items mimicry evolved the
scientists witnessed in silico the
evolution of a lie
I think that's cool maybe you disagree
maybe you think that data that only
comes from actual real life experiments
or observations in the wild should count
when we're trying to understand how
Evolution Works I'd love to hear your
thoughts about that down in the comments
so long for now subscribe and hit that
little bell icon if you like this and
you want to see more John Perry signing
out so long for now stay curious